[Music]
all living organisms are capable of
giving birth to young ones which are
either exactly same or somewhat similar
to them can you tell me what is this
process of giving birth to an offspring
known as the process is called
reproduction in simple terms it's
defined as the process in which living
organisms give birth to an offspring
which is the same or similar to them now
when I say living organisms it should
include plants as well right yes of
course we have seen a new plant emerging
from a seed when soul in the ground
where does this seed come from it comes
from some plant right absolutely
but wait have we seen all the plants
always giving us flowers fruits and
seeds no there are many plants that do
not bear flowers and fruits so don't
these plants reproduce or do they
reproduce by some other means let's
answer all these questions in this video
reproduction in plants can occur in two
major ways one type is asexual
reproduction and the second is sexual
reproduction sexual reproduction as the
name suggests involves sex cells or
gametes so a new individual is born when
gametes from both male and female
parents fuse now can you guess what
asexual reproduction will be in contrast
to the previous type asexual
reproduction does not involve gametes it
is a type in which some part of the
parent body will be capable of growing
into a new organism interesting isn't it
but which part of the parent body will
grow into a new organism based on
various factors asexual reproduction is
further categorized into subtypes a few
of these include the vegetative
propagation fragmentation budding and
spore formation let's get introduced to
each type in detail in the upcoming
videos
[Music]
you